a new survey found that one in five
people in the UK would be willing to
have sex with a robot 2,000 people were
quizzed on their attitudes towards
Androids
and 46% surveyed admitted that they'd
either have sex with a robot or not
judge others who chose to have robot sex
to me this is just the way things are
going
yes people will start having sex with
robots in the not-too-distant future and
they're probably partly doing it already
and the honda thing and all that would
you have sex with the robot you know I I
guess they would depend on a robot I
really can't imagine so if it was a
robot I was like oh okay well that makes
sense in the context of AI where people
are not allowed to reproduce anymore
because the earth is too small and can't
sustain them so that's kind of what it
was one of the parts so you know the
idea of that it makes sense in a logical
sort of science fiction I like how you
took this immediately to the
intellectual part with a robot busy I
you know I don't know they're already
doing this in Japan I mean they're
already if you ever happen to stumble
upon any of the sex conventions from
Japan's photos from those are quite
insane and interesting and you're like
wow okay as long as you already have the
money for that then you can buy your own
and it's already happening now yeah so
there is a movement in Japan called
otaku which is a movement for the rising
number of men that are opting for
relationships with virtual women so
there that's not actually a robot that's
just a virtual but you can see it going
to that place it's it's the next step
before the before the Jude Law thing sex
with robots and II know how do you feel
that no well we're so far off from Jude
Law robots exactly if you look at these
people
or these people like look I'm already
doing it yes you see yeah if you look at
these robots these androids like they
are terrifying first of all yeah second
of all we've cast my show the number one
rule the number one prevail
rule is light just like freaked me out
yeah the robots the rule is that they
will they will kill us and and so if you
start submitting to them in the bedroom
they are going to be able to be much
more persuasive when the apocalypse
doesn't if it if it comes eat milk cows
so you're all right so we'll just move
to that for a second you believe the
robots will take over one day is no I
mean yes yes yes so so the sex would
just be dangerous because it'll
facilitate it happening faster the
general idea well I had another idea
that came up under I was reading it was
oh wait a second that kind of makes
sense not just in this in a context of
the otaku in Japan that you're talking
about but also what about say a country
like China where a one-child policy has
resulted in a huge gender imbalance you
know whether more went men and there
aren't enough women then to get married
to so you've got a whole generation or
more of men who have no outlet for that
so when you got angry horny men what
happens will you get wars and stuff that
was the first commercial cyber not war
yeah is that a good tagline like cyber
love yeah that's it well then of course
this will lead to ultimately robots
having sex with robots and then what
about babies what about same what about
same sex robots I mean it's all gonna be
there what about robot human marriage
they did an episode of Futurama about
robosexual marriage which was pretty
perfect but I mean if we go if you just
extrapolate like that I mean someone
will fall in love with their robot
there's a guy somewhere I think in the
UK that's trying to marry his computer
right now because he loves it so much
you know blah blah so I mean is that
crazy to be thinking about all this
stuff you know I don't think it's crazy
to be thinking about it might be
premature but eventually I think we will
probably have to discuss and figure out
the ethics of all of this I mean I know
it does about me mature Robo Jack
ulation
is it right you know is there an ethical
issue with you know with relationships
you know what if people abandon their
relationships in order to have a robot
their robot that never complains and
ever asks you hey do the dishes
you know if you
robots battery died is that like
neglectful homicide killing it I don't
like I wonder yeah I mean what I'm still
trying to figure out is where we reach
the difference between like a flashlight
you know and a blow-up doll and then an
actual Android robot you know is that is
this like and that's the gateway drug
right to Robo well that's why I'm saying
this is all happening so you have the
know the flashlight which is basically a
piece of plastic that you can whack off
with the second thing you said then the
block well we had blowup dolls back in
the so this is all just natural
progression it doesn't sex and porn just
sort of lead the way I mean that it's
changed video right from from beta or
master beta so like sex just kind of
leads the way and we just follow right
yeah it does seem to be the thing that
that folks focus on mostly when they're
working on technology it's like oh let's
not figure out a better way to I don't
know feed the world let's instead figure
out how to have better sex you know
that's that's the driver of much of the
technology yeah I don't I don't
understand why why we're so surprised by
this or anything you know and this it
does seem like the natural progression I
do think it's weird you know yeah I
don't know that I'm gonna find myself in
a robo parlor any you know usually the
people that are against robot sex are
the ones secretly having it at home
wanting it at airplane yeah throw right
robot sex maybe by the time that we have
to address the robot sexual
relationships where the robosexuals as
they call them we will at that point be
letting dogs get married and tend to
people and cats and so by that time it
won't be a big deal
you